when you guys read the scripts and start
to see how the season was going to play
out what was your initial reaction we
were given the first couple episodes at
first i thought it was amazing this
isn't your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy this is the sparrow
academy
it was really thrilling to read and to
see the sparrows come in and what went
on with them i wanted to find out where
lyla had been and actually we don't
until later on in the series so i sort
of had to ask steve hold on what's going
on here where's she been and so i could
inject that into the episode
how about you
well there's like there's a pitch
meeting and then you get the first
couple episodes and they continue to
change as time goes on and new drafts
come in
uh i would say the pitch meetings are
always the most exciting because you get
sort of like an overview of the
different things that are going to
happen in the season without ever
getting too specific yeah but from the
get-go it's
been a joy to like oh we get to do that
and that and that and that and it
culminates to this
and then
finally when it's all together
uh and summed all the different layers
of production come together to make the
season of television and you watch it at
home
it was an absolute pleasure i i was
blown away by the season i'm sure you
guys knew really early on at this but
elliott's character fully becoming
victor was incredibly
powerful and but at the same time like a
subtle uh and nuanced moments in the
show what was it like either reading
that or or you know watching it come
together beautiful it was so lovely that
they um wrote it in such a authentic and
sensitive way
and
i think we were just really happy to see
the amount of support that elliot was
getting you know insane same feeling
yeah i think she said it perfectly
scenes like that it's more so like a
joyous thing rather than it is pressure
because
it there's so much discussion went into
like the tone of how it would come
across and yeah i thought it was handled
beautifully and
a joy to watch that sort of very happy
moment for all of these characters come
out and like it's great there's moments
those moments in particular
it's not that you can see the workings
behind the scenes but what you just see
what comes across on screen is
like an incredible amount of love it's
like it like seeps through the camera
like you can tell that uh you can tell
how much care there is into it and and
uh and it was almost like
some of the most moving in a season that
has a lot of moving moments you know
right up there uh they were really well
done
talk to me about the um
the footloose dance number that's
i mean i'm sure that was like what weeks
of rehearsal
an entire week to shoot what was it
we were in quarantine for like i want to
say somewhere around two weeks of like
dance rehearsal where we were all just
doing it over zoom and uh had to sort of
learn the choreography in our own space
and
it was quite a challenge i struggled
with that
looks great though i mean it's a fun
sequence it's really fun to watch
good looking for you
spoiler alert
what was it like for you guys to get to
spend some time together working as team
partners this season so much fun
um it was really uh
an absolute delight like uh we start the
season off and really hating each other
and and um
not journaling and then after time
there's this admiration that they have
and um
they become friends kind of yeah i'd say
because
it was really fun to to have this this
fight at the beginning and we got quite
a few weeks of rehearsal with that
because it kept getting pushed and so we
just kept adding more and more to this
bike because i think we just really
enjoyed it it's also technically
interesting how they had to shoot around
it i thought it was an interesting
concept for a fight okay how was your
team look at that yeah it wasn't
originally in the script it was like
there's um there's more
here there's more hatred here how can we
do this great bits though like that and
also like the hallway bit with the
briefcase and like going through the
whole
sort of collapsed 1960s time commission
thing i think they're both really good
at what they do so i think it was really
yeah really fun to to pair up where
would that leave these characters if
there is a season four now we we
are closing moments is our our
our group is
essentially powerless potentially um
what do you hope happens in your
in the next season should there be one i
mean like what does five look like
and what is it what does his life look
like if he's you know
continues to be a six-year-old man in a
like a 15 year old six-year-old body i'd
be curious to know what you think
happens
because there's only so much one can say
right
what do you what are your theories for
this
i feel like
five is not ready to lay down and just
let and go on living as a as a teenager
i feel like he must try to fix it but i
feel like i like lila i feel like might
be interested in in having the family
and actually moving on with life you
think five would want to reject the
reality and lila would find some place
in it interesting that's what i think
although maybe that's two maybe that's
too late maybe i don't know maybe it
does happen not at all we'll see it's
quite the ending though uh it's very
ambiguous the way they've done it
mystery
[Music]